les chéris savez ce qui arrive là tout
de suite de carrière va pas démissionner
les légendaires camier aprilia la caméra
cachée degré guillotin ce qu'on peut le
faire tout de suite ce que vous voulez
est-ce que je peux lancer le jingle des
cafetières parce que c'est les premiers
capteurs de la saison bah oui mais trop
d'émotion dans ce coup là encore le
jingle on va dire au revoir à dire merci
à dire d'avant
[Applaudissements]
c'est
[Musique]
les cafetières dans mon jean luc lemoine
ce sont les premiers la saison et que
j'aime quand il est près de moi oh là là
yeddou ça fait plaisir
alors ça serait des questions un peu
spéciale ce soir car j'ai pas d'offre vu
qu'on vient répondre
harry reid m'a dit ah quand même ça
serait bien qu'ils aient des quatre
quarts la première semaine
ce à quoi j'ai répondu syrie c'est pas
possible j'ai rien et c'est vrai il m'a
dit je comprends mon frérot démerde toi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et tes on était au restaurant parce
qu'on va en voir là je vous dis on fait
un dîner de rentrée voilà avec tous les
to let alors tous ceux qui ont une année
de présence rien voilà et vous vous
rendrez compte ya des gens qui n'étaient
pas là non tout le monde avait une année
de présence là ici si j'ai ma mère avant
d'y être parce qu'il est considéré comme
faisant partie voilà nîmes et vannes h
en lui que pendant le dîner m'a dit j'ai
pas beaucoup de matière mais vous le
savez c'est un génie et heureusement il
y avait le pilote donc pour la première
fois vous montrer sur le numéro zéro où
l'on s'active
oui je vous montre des images que
d'habitude je montre pas vrai voilà
toute une question
bonjour je m'appelle claude tout l'été
j'ai lu que l'émission allait devenir
plus intelligente
donc je voulais savoir qu'est ce que
vous allez faire des anciens
chroniqueurs
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors vive le petit mot sur vous vous ne
répondiez il ya beaucoup de gens qui se
demandent sur twitter pourquoi camille
n'est pas là aujourd'hui
camille est là lundi mardi mercredi
parce que tous les mercredis ce sera les
quatre tirs de jean luc lemoine
donc voilà qu'à mistral à trois fois par
semaine parce qu'il y avait déjà des
gens qui disent oui mais camille n'est
pas là il sera de retour
s'il est prévu c'était prévu depuis le
début de l'année exactement un an avant
je comprends votre question kurde et la
réponse est
concernant les chroniqueurs c'est pas
grand chose je veux juste vous dire qu'à
la fin la semaine une vente de trottoir
est prévu devant ses beats si vous
l'achetez un chroniqueur pour de la déco
possible c'est cyril a par exemple chez
lui une enora qu'il a reconverti en
table basse cette musique est moins cool
sont disponibles chez des besoins d'un
lampadaire
en tout cas pour le reste les missions a
changé c'est vrai nouvelle équipe mais
son vous avez sans doute vu la photo
officielle
regardez 29 personnes et encore ils sont
pas tous là le mieux c'est que si nous
les présente
j'ai représenté tous les tous les
chroniqueurs et ayala beaucoup vous
connaissez bien là que vous connaissez
pas mais mme moyal axe collait pas
même moi y'a là je suis même pas les
mêmes enlisé mais il ya des gars que je
connais pas sur la photo d'un bon
normalement envoyé cette photo
normalement on en perd la moitié me
descend
déjà quand on peut quand on goûte les
images devraient pas menacer des images
qu'on a jamais montré donc je sens qu'on
va avoir beaucoup de problèmes avec ses
qualités ça sonne bien en confiance pour
un pilote même si celui-ci d'un bon ba
112 100 perdent c'est possible qui a dit
qu'il ne connaissait pas tout le monde
mais qui a quand même tenu à présenter
tous les chroniqueurs avant la photo ben
vous voyez le temps que ça dure quand il
nous présente au début on dit que neuf
là on était 29,1
mais bon cyril tenais à dire un petit
mot gentil à chacun il comme ici la
dernière recrue annoncée sur les sites
médias
yasmine glaude soglo va que dorénavant
nous appellerons yasmine pour des
raisons d'orthophonie elle a 20 ans et
quand où et quand vous la voyez vous dit
vous voyez moi je lis king a bien marqué
sur une erreur
[Musique]
mais à côté
elle n'a pas besoin elle n'a pas besoin
de victimes non mais franchement il ya
quand même une génération d'écart là
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que je vous dis oui mais
lequel mlb oui même dans les loges et ou
alors je dis que je suis surpris oui
qu'est ce que tu as fait pour être aussi
belle si vous avez fait rien je me suis
reposé au soleil d'accord très bonne
réponse merci et l'autre sous sol à
jennyfer parti alors les bras d'honneur
cheese est belle ça veut dire je suis
content d'être un bon je vais pas vous
passer toutes les présentations
je vais faire un petit focus sur quelque
chose que les chroniqueurs n'ont
peut-être pas remarqué les musiques
envoyé par la régie avant chacune de nos
présentations
je pense que le mec qui faisait les
envois été pris de court il a paniqué il
a fallu qu'il a promises en trouant 29
musique ou qu'au début il a fait sobre
comme pour caroline ithurbide ans et
caroline ithurbide
[Applaudissements]
ces soldes ça fait un peu génériques
télé un peu miss france et puis après il
a essayé de personnaliser et là on a
découvert ce que chacun lui inspirer
merci de mettre dans sa tête pour
comprendre c'est pas moi qui parle ces
mecs du son alors alors bernard montiel
alors comment résumer sa carrière baba
sy je sais montiel cm bronze et le
branleur qui est toujours en vacances et
voilà on y va c'est bernard montiel
[Applaudissements]
bravo au maillet jordi mayoral m'excite
pas mal géré a dit mayer je lui met une
petite musique de strip tease géraldine
maillet qui était
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon christophe carrière bon il a une
tête de dépressif
on va lui mettre sa l'émission elle
existait pas il voulait des gènes dedans
christophe carrière merci d'être là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est vraiment ce qu'ils étaient divisés
nous on n'a pas entendu parce qu'on
faisait pas tout mais c'est ouf je
continue alors et chamanga annonça j'ai
l'impression qu'il a un peu repris
et ça tombe bien là je vais faire autant
on dit ça bon appétit de katy perry
alors yasmine yasmine ob
alors je sais pas qui c'est mais même
rappelle quelqu'un quand même merci
yasmine d'être avec nous qui rejoint
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là
rachid arhab oh [ __ ] alors là désolé
rachid raha moi j'ai plus d'idées un non
mais c'est vrai au psg il on démarre moi
j'ai raté là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les derniers on la passe tout de suite
se mettre dedans c'est parce que sinon
ça sera dur pour l'enchaînement quoi
vous vous laissez les gens lui c'est
votre émission mais c'était comme ça sur
chacun emilie lopez vous allez voir il
va partir sur une piste est filmé en
loisir annonce est pas la bonne
vaut mieux faire autre chose emilie
lopez elle se cache
et au même
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il est fait partie sur bella est
finalement il s'est rabattu sur imagined
dragon c'est magnifique on peut bien sûr
ils ont ça nous fait quoi y'a quoi après
bon bah en fait il ya du texte et des
images broderick alors j'ai été sur les
musiques de présentation des
chroniqueurs royaux chacun avait vu une
musique personnalisés j'ai pas tous
voulaient passer mais je vous assure que
c'est vrai après 2h30 de présentation de
cyril puisque sa durée quand même un
bouton a duré peu en tant que pilote à
un moment quand même on est arrivé au
moment de la photo
voilà ce que ça inspire et aux mecs qui
envahit la musique je vous promets c'est
vraiment ce qui était diffusée en
plateau on n'a pas remarqué ça bonsoir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les
j'aimais j'avais montré que la musique
bella enfin j'avais fait écouter la
musique bella c'était un peu malhonnête
tout à l'heure parce que c'est surtout
parce que cette année nous accueillons
la jolie kelly b noviny
[Applaudissements]
la balade et puis de mathieu visionique
les lives et d'aurélie encore un nom
bien facile à prononcer heureusement
jean michel trois moyens de simplifier
les choses à la djette de l'émission je
vous cache pas aussi c'était wistar
bonnet lien oui c'est un beau dos mais
kelly alors je n'arrive jamais cv
novelli avait ouvert nos vélos vélib
kelly mer quelle image est appelé je
vais t'appeler kelly new delhi mais nous
et avec nos oppositions y avait créé
binaire et jean-michel loudes
beaucoup de gens s'inquiétaient des
changements apportés à l'émission cette
année et se poser une question
essentielle jean-michel sera-t-il
toujours aussi lourd une réponse est oui
sur la présentation de cyril on ya cru
au changement mais ça a tenu cinq
secondes
alors il a décidé de changer de look
cette année sachez qu'il sera toujours
en costume trois pièces et cravate il a
décidé d'être le mentaliste
ne touche pas à mon pote
[Applaudissements]
des numéros zéro c'est pas censé être
diffusés je me suis un peu lâché juste
avant le commencé c'était une source de
sécurité
j'ai pas dû une fois de plus lundi alors
là c'est fini ça c'est un mot qui la
famille de son vocabulaire et bravo à ce
que vous fiez pas aux costumes on a
changé le papier mais à l'intérieur le
bonbon c'est le même alors quand en plus
vous le mettez en présence d'une jolie
jeune femme le vernis craque elle est
très vite vous allez voir et c'est votre
droit
c'est ce crime tout le monde des
sublimes franchement quand je débute
dans la loge tout à l'heure mais ses
terres on nous il a demandé le photo ac
il est engagé sur la photo je copiais
les magnifiques viendrait galant quand
même et m'a dit il transpirait des
fesses
[Applaudissements]
une panne technique de drague pour
préparer cette rubrique je me suis tapé
toutes les saisons du mentalist a aucun
mouvement parisien
l'improvisation de jean michel a une
c'est très possible donc l'apparence on
oublie on s'est dit que ce qui avait pu
changer pendant l'été c'était la diction
de jean mimi comme c'est un bosseur
infatigable défend pourtant juillet août
marc espalioux contaminé aussi la
réponse tout de suite avec c'est exclu
[Musique]
bah c'est pas j'ai même envoyé un sms
sympathique voilà un petit coup ici
xavier savamment jean-mi très bien merci
le taf avait fait qu'on prend des
vacances avec votre fille comme
d'habitude oui mais j'ai beaucoup bossé
aussi partie si ce n'est sur le tour de
france avec maxime valaisan connaître
pmp il avait un peu les mots à moi vous
êtes pire qu'avant sur des cas
d'agressions peinture je suis tout jeune
un autre qui n'a pas changé pendant
l'été ces mecs singinois oui enfin si il
a un peu changé maintenant il est auto
suffit suffisant avant ils attendaient
que cyril de relance maintenant plus là
panis relance tout seul fait une phrase
il imagine que si lui dit et répond de
suite c'est très étonnant et on a
proposé un nouveau look houmadi fini les
bombers sont en taule mais uniquement
des baisses avec cravate ou c'est pas
mal ça fait plaisir
on n'a rien dit j'ai passé
descente du parc b
[Applaudissements]
je pense que c'est pareil pour tous les
chroniqueurs mois cet été beaucoup de
gens m'ont demandé ce qu'il fallait
faire pour devenir chroniqueur il
fallait avoir un cursus particulier
alors honnêtement cela nous demande et
j'en sais rien un car même quand on
demande au nouveau pourquoi ils ont été
choisis c'est pas très clair
un exemple et yasmine alors à côté vous
faites pousser quoi bon parce qu'il ya
plein de gens qui se demandent ils
disent comment mais j'étais au chômage
comme nous tous grill comment est ce que
vous avez découvert
quelles sont ses compétences le pitre
alors c'est la productrice de l'émission
de nouvelles productrice qui a kind a
présenté et j'ai eu un flash comme outre
elle se fâche c'est basé sur quoi
exactement
c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas parlé
[Applaudissements]
elle sera vécue avec la semaine
prochaine je crois qu à l débat réel et
ça va donc pour entrer dans l'équipe il
faut juste croisé syrie et surtout ne
pas lui parler
oui et vous avec ça autre nouveauté
découvert par le pilote cette année
valérie bénaïm se lance dans la vanne au
bas du maillot rose c'est bien
reconverti sur nbc du bon bah qu'est
j'entends j'ai très peu de retours sais
qui mais on peut régler ça s'il vous
plaît si tu veux tu loues levier on lui
dit au finish c'est pas mal ça fait
plaisir
[Applaudissements]
très drôle au pilote candé les pilotes
et est vrai que tu as même humour que
maxime guény ces coups durs comme vous
avez compris et que ce jeu de mots
lamentable que rachid ramda rejoint jeu
pour le plus grand plaisir de jean
michel il ya toujours admiré sa carrière
c'est un des plus grands journalistes
ont eu en france il est avec nous
maintenant il est sûr aussi sûr ces news
avec patrick poivre d'arvor rachid arhab
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
allez pour finir et comme c'est une
espèce de mise en bouche des cas tiers
aujourd'hui
je me suis dit que ça serait bien
d'envoyer tout le monde au bistrot à a
laissé le principe au ralenti des images
est comme ça on a l'impression que tout
le monde est bourré
[Musique]
il
4 for species dupas est ce que ça peut
encore reparti aimant ses morts au chili
les vacances il ya surtout le d'école de
voile à la décoloration soleil ça
réveille je voulais quelque chose ou
jamais dit à avoue m'excite rappelé à
beaucoup pape léon la porno on appelle
poids norme serait comment ça va vous
très bien très enfants vraiment ah oui
mr oui et alors
donc je pose ça oui la langue
allez-y oui à manger la vrae vallée
parce que c'est des petits chaussons
anodine final c'est beaucoup beaucoup et
même si ça moi je n'aurais même pas même
pas relevé
mais je trouve que enfin deux élus
démocrates et les autres
vif montrez-moi blues vainqueurs
parce que je crois que ça commençait mal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]